how much would the first two games do
that we make the rules around here we
make them you go first
great yeah usually show me how it's done
here yeah all right so you can kind of
look yeah and I touch it do I have to
just can't yeah
okay I have the one hand wow you went
for that one huh
yeah I like to be a little hard on em G
over there sir look at the fairness oh I
know
Brad IV you know I'm saying some games
like get in I know what time it is this
one out for my confidence is low like
900 yards love oh hey we own the team
one hand Melvin oh my bad my bad
that's all right well let he slide
before my bet
alright so Sims going this side right
yeah a little down work he still hasn't
got this one out yeah peebo or don't got
doggy and you have to cuz you're gonna
keep creating levels well you're so
gentle wow what a nice touch you have
this one are you thinking right uh
Charlo push so it doesn't move you can
try the other one ooh that feels like
pretty hard no don't touch that
no I tried that oh that's nothing tried
that one mhm that doesn't feel good yeah
I think this is the last of all so
that's the keep now you got to see if it
uh can move
don't steal he's play your game you
[Laughter]
he found he found the right one that
moved so easily
well done let go well done
don't we suppose they own this up I went
on an angle
you're very particular with rules from
just saying I'm just going off what you
mean oh okay get your hands off there
it's his turn mover yeah that's the one
yeah go really push it push out through
you see which one yeah push as hard as
you can
that bay move them grow yeah there you
go
Wow Oh oh crap dart oh gosh all right
I'm worried Sims you got this well done
hey everyone's going here try try some
of these bad boys I know but they don't
look they feel real hmm I don't know
left go I think you got it I think so
oh it's really tight here Correll push
that back in a little bit all right now
now move that side like kind of like
keep going no no yeah just keep going
baby we've hit it like that like Al and
then out I don't know man this thing
yeah push it yeah you turn you are
scores also you could put it on the top
with two hands though yeah y'all ain't
telling me that though I'm over there
trying to do one hell
you've been very delicate Oh
[Music]
gets caught on the cloth and just yeah
rip it all off we should add a dartboard
or some sorry crew ma'am dad huh all
right this thing is real shaky but I
think this is the play left go oh you
don't think so these fall
Oh like a glove oh please
standing room mmm pushing that huh
a little tap tap tap-a-roo you found it
oh yeah balance it out because it's
already leaning over there yeah you know
what that he's not used to being hit
like that now that I'm back since I'm on
this team I'm dude hit him again
I like teamwork works you need to be
roughed up a little I really don't want
these currents I think it's got to be
here all right but I want to really make
it hard no let's just try to go to the
next round there is no more round no
well yes this is another room they could
screw it up mm-hmm all right I gotta
stop you're good now
well done yeah well done whoa
nine hundred and seventy-five yards
Melvin Gordon and so yeah then I go to
table or table top down there how do I
hold him and then going cannot go in the
top three don't know you're gonna know
that you can't go in the top three why
because then it's cheating cuz it's like
there's not enough weight to keep them
you got to be wondering two hands all
right I gotta go I'm just here to remind
you I'm sweating
how come today bro oh it's stuck we're
get out of here okay thanks thanks for
that thank you other side other side
isn't alright Sims engine where did he
just take it out of this one right I
don't know about those dude no what try
yeah what about
oh this has a little movement all right
but you I need it I know try this one
no well no no just try just test the
three yeah negative Ghost Rider that's
that's too touchy when I got a little
raggedy he's so raggedy oh my god a mess
on you he did he did now on the Aaron
Rodgers of Jenga he the only crap whoa
yeah you're pointing is so reckless I
swear maybe he'll be trying to tell me
oh this must be jammed this is actually
a fun game I've never done this i played
inna probably once in my life there's
big trouble this is my dream okay take
it from the first two movies the phrase
you using me it might be what hurt my
knee turns might be Kurt oh yeah this is
my dream this is my if it falls right
here with Melvin Ingram it's called car
alarm alarm alarm strikes back one hand
one hand I want to be one of those dudes
that like punches the middle oh my gosh
he just twisted the half the thing on it
you got a got a pinch it right there's
not how they going don't I'm telling you
maybe wanted to pinch it I got listen
bro he twisted it from here it up look
at it that ain't going man ain't gon
stuck over its
wait a minute how many rows though three
can't do the top three one two three
I'm just trying to figure out when
there's a time let me get him a fit now
yeah you wanted to see you are too risky
middle oh it's not only one what's wrong
worth it was this one it's the only one
that movement seems like curtains do you
mind if I stand right behind you okay Oh
his hands are heavy and big oh man
that's it
what fall mulch oh it's going it has to
help get ain't going nowhere see I told
you what if you don't fall it oh boy a
ball
[Applause]
all right Oh worry here hey next year
yeah I'm gonna pull up again right we
ain't finishing weeks next year next
year we'll come back with a whole new
set ever played before well he lost two
rounds that's why y'all been losing a
lot